to you what does the average person look  like  are you are you the average person i  don't think so no  okay i agree yeah  um you know i i think the average person  is does not have the time or the  interest for a lot of these questions  yet they still struggle with them  you know i think the average person has  a generic middle class job  maybe partially college educated but  not always um and feels these things  they feel  kind of the the social  fabric unwinding underneath them  they they see things on social media and  on the news that  is confusing and upsetting but they  don't have  the time they haven't had the time to  investigate these things further